all right Emily yes Emily uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm from a small town in Texas called
Sour Lake
um it's sort of near Houston what was
your family like
fun cute family my mom and dad are
divorced
uh my mom was married to someone that
didn't make my childhood difficult their
relationship was quite difficult and so
there was a lot of fighting and stuff
going on but
still love him still love her me and her
are very close my dad was like one of my
best friends we did everything together
we played Sports we did everything and I
have a younger brother and an older
sister
and how far you in school
what was that how far did you go in
school oh I went to um partial college
so yes I moved to Los Angeles at 18 to
go to New York Film Academy what did you
want to do with your be an actor yes I
wanted to act and model
yeah but you got derailed a little bit a
little bit yeah
um
so tell me about that because uh what
you're doing is something that I think a
lot of
young ladies are doing yes for sure
um yeah so I basically I moved here for
acting and modeling to Los Angeles and I
became a personal trainer along the way
I got into social media along the way
and then doing only fans kind of fell
into my lap and
honestly it's been life-changing and
it's been something that I didn't
necessarily expect to be doing but now
that I'm here I'm
amazed and grateful to be honest
it's been a good experience
yeah overall it's been a really good
experience
and you're making good money I assume
I am making good money I'm making six
figures
um I'm making more money than I expected
to be making at this age and it's pretty
exciting
so you're shooting like videos or photos
or yes so I do videos and photos I
um do have nudity on my page some girls
don't you really don't have to some
girls go really hardcore with it and
have explicit things on their page I do
that separately selling content but not
on my main wall on my main wall I just
have sort of videos getting ready
topless
um let's see videos you know just doing
household things like people like that
it's it's really cool sexy photos that I
feel amazing and beautiful in and that
other people want to have access to and
they can't publicly online so you tell
me your boyfriend helps you he does
he shoots the yes he shoots a lot of my
content yeah he does
how does this make you feel
you're I guess a form of sex worker yeah
I am and actually whenever you don't
have to have contact with anyone
exactly yeah that's the amazing part and
honestly since
I don't know I guess maybe
15 or 16 when I found out kind of like
what Playboy is I've been like in love
and obsessed just with the idea of being
like nude and feeling still sexy and
confident and beautiful whenever you
know I'm from a small town in Texas like
people being nude is like no don't do
that around me like we don't do that
here and for me it's just always been
something that I feel good about and
inspired about and just it empowers me
in a sense so yeah no I can see why
you're successful yeah thank you
what so you're you're the clients will
subscribe or or pay for special content
or something like that exactly both yeah
so people will subscribe
um and you know they can buy up to a
year they can buy six months they can go
month to month
and they can also pay for Content
separately they can tip me or they can
request in a video and as long as I'm
comfortable with doing the request then
it's a go so I get requests sometimes
it's really something simple like just
shower just literally showering nude
nothing sexual going on you're just
showering or cooking nude or like
sucking my own Toes or just like showing
off like the soles of my feet like
there's a lot of requests like that and
then there's like you know bouncing
things like that other requests but yeah
that's what turned that on yeah exactly
how do you feel about this I mean you're
a sex object basically for sure yeah and
to be honest I actually feel really
empowered by it that there's been I mean
I started modeling at 16. and pretty
much ever since then there's been
multiple photo shoots that I've gone on
where I was sexually assaulted or just
talked to like they're really trying to
hint at wanting to do other things and
and it was just always so
I guess disempowering or I would just
feel like oh God like this always
happens like why does this keep
happening and how do I prevent it
and
that's what gives me power and
confidence like in doing only fans is
literally everything is on my terms
everything if I'm not comfortable with a
video or photo request I just tell that
person and for the most part they always
understand and don't really push the
issue further but just literally
everything's in my power I can make a
video or photo that I want to make and
it's only me involved so everything is
going to go fine and I know that so what
percentage does only fans take they take
20 20 yes
I mean it's it's the safest I would
think of all the possibilities for a
girl who wants to use her beauty and
yeah sexuality to definitely yeah I
would think so for sure for sure it's
interesting for me I've thought a lot
about this because I do so many videos
that are related to this topic I have
two daughters that are a little younger
than you you're you're 25 yes
and
I just you know I see the struggles that
a lot of women have to survive and make
money and pay the bills and
pay the rent and so on
and being a sex worker is so frowned
upon Yeah by Society yeah yeah I know
I'm not making a judgment I'm just
noticing that this is what's going on
for sure yeah in the world in our
country
and they'll teach classes and how to
you know run a a restaurant or do other
careers
that often fail yeah but for a young
lady like yourself
I would think starting this would be a
pretty there's a high probability you'll
be successful absolutely and making
multiple six figures
for sure and I do think actually if I
could have dropped the fear of that
judgment sooner in my life I think I
could have been making six figures at a
very young age maybe 20 or 21 like some
of these accordions According to some of
the sex workers that I've interviewed if
you were 15 you could be making a killer
that too yeah honestly that's true
illegally I guess that's true
um yeah but yeah honestly a lot of why I
didn't start earlier and go all in with
this why I did start at 2020 I started
was because of the fear of judgment I
didn't want like content to get leaked
and someone one of my friends or one of
my family members see it or just
really just anyone in society that I
didn't want to see it I felt like almost
shame from it so it really took me doing
a lot of personal work to lift that
shame and just face like no Emily this
is what you love to do like you enjoy
this and you know you can give yourself
a really good life if you go all in your
boyfriend's totally into it totally undo
it for sure
yeah and actually I do know that there's
a lot of boyfriends who aren't because
of the whole judgment thing and um just
the way that yeah I guess it's
everyone's personal decision like how
uptight you're going to be about exactly
sex exactly yeah for sure
yeah I see I see as I've been doing
these interviews for years
um like my stand on it is relaxed a bit
yeah for sure you know when I was when I
was younger I was I was like oh no
that's bad that's wrong yeah yeah
whether you're uh
a stripper or a sex uh
a prostitute or a uh a sugar baby or
whatever you know it's like where else
where else can I can you make the money
you're making yeah exactly 25 years old
I know exactly
I mean you probably won't be able to do
it forever but you I think you'll have a
long career and you'll save your money
make a killing in the meantime you're
saving money I'm sure right for sure
yeah oh yeah I'm doing my best I I
didn't really realize the whole taxes
thing whenever I first started so yeah
you're learning that was kind of a slap
in the face I was like oh my God I have
to speed and save now but I did it now
I'm trying to get caught up I've made
some bad business decisions in this time
where I've been making more money which
I think is just going to come along with
it um it's just a life thing that will
happen but overall I'm very happy
financially
what did you learn about men from doing
this and seeing their requests and the
demand that you have I've learned that
actually a lot of them are actually very
respectful it's not necessarily what I
think a lot of women have like a skewed
idea oh men are just dogs or like men
are gross or oh all they want to think
about is sex but it's really just
what we all want to think about like we
all want to explore and if they see me
online they think I'm hot and they join
and they have a request I'm very open to
hearing about it if it's something I'm
not comfortable with almost I really
can't think of an instant instance where
they were actually angry that I wasn't
comfortable with it so I've learned you
know they really are just trying to
survive like the rest of us in your
personal life have you run into friends
or relatives that are like uptight about
it and think what you're doing is wrong
or judge you know past judgment I
actually haven't had any friends at
least tell me but I I have a really
open-minded friend group so I think I'm
really lucky for that and that's kind of
who I've placed around me
I do think that some of my family is
kind of like I don't know I kind of wish
she was doing something else but they
don't really tell me just
it's fine I mean we have our own our
opinions if people aren't okay with what
I do then that's okay and
it doesn't bother me too much it used to
bother me a lot that's why I was like
very hesitant to start only fans
Americans can be very uptight about sex
yeah exactly exactly
have there been any surprises with your
only fans
um well I actually did have a family
member who sent me
an explicit photo of themselves
thinking that I didn't know who it was
and was like asking me to
basically rate their private area and
that was quite an experience that became
a whole thing in my family and that was
pretty
uncomfortable for me I'll bet yeah I
felt pretty taken advantage of in that
situation
that was pretty weird yeah that's
interesting so you you also had a little
controversy with something that happened
at Disneyland here in Los Angeles yes
um I wore can I stand
uh sure see my outfit okay
so
I wore this outfit this exact outfit
outfit entirely
um I didn't wear it to Disneyland I was
in the downtown Disney parking lot just
making some videos just to be silly no
one was around
and I think it's funny I think it's a
funny outfit I work with this company
towels and yeah I just thought it was
silly and it ended up getting blown up
way out of proportion there was like
articles about it this woman wore this
outfit at Disneyland and yeah it was a
whole thing it went viral like on social
media and like on Tick Tock and
Instagram people were like mad and of
course everyone made it about oh my
goodness why would she wear that around
kids people wear micro bikinis around
kids it's literally covering everything
so I really think it's just
people being jealous and things like
that which is another problem and
another thing that hopefully Society can
work on
we're all trying to compete with each
other all the time yeah the Envy yeah
the envy and jealousy yeah exactly I
think that's the most comes from of
where the issue came from not actually
about the kids
yeah
what advice would you give to somebody
who's thinking about doing this for a
career
if someone was thinking about doing this
for a career I would say like go for it
it's a lot more work than people think
it is it is a lot more work you
definitely do have to be on your stuff
when you do it but if it's something
that people are thinking about I really
think that you should go for it I think
that it can totally turn your life
around and change your life and that
yeah just go for it honestly and go was
just all in with it at your comfort
level obviously but and save money for
taxes and save money for taxes for sure
do that yes
it's one of the few sex worker careers
that you actually pay taxes exactly yeah
for sure
and and so the request that you'll get
do you do sometimes
turn them down I'm sure
yeah sometimes I do sometimes because
they sometimes want you to be explicit
with your words and the video like
and yeah sometimes it's just too much
and I'm just like okay that's not really
something that's that's past my comfort
level where I feel like at that point I
might as well just do porn that's what
it feels like even though what you're
doing basically porn
sometimes it is yeah sometimes basically
but the amazing thing like I said is
that it's all in my control right so
yeah and it'll be with my partner not
with you know other people
or alone with just myself yeah which is
also good
do you have any regrets in your life
hmm any regrets
honestly like to be totally honest my
only regret which it's really even not
because I think that I had to go through
certain life experiences to get where I
am today but is that I didn't go fully
in on who I am and who I actually wanted
to be and wanted to do until very
recently like within the last couple of
years because I was afraid of the
judgment and I was afraid of what other
people might think of me so ever since
I've lifted that I'm just like hey this
is me this is what I do I love myself
and I still think I'm amazing and if you
don't you just don't have to be in my
life I would think as a
uh sex worker somebody who is
getting all this judgment from others
if I were in your shoes I would use it
to
motivate myself to be even nicer and
sweeter and kinder to others exactly and
people want to hate you
but they can and you're like what are
you hating exactly what exactly are you
hating for sure yeah that's honestly
that's exactly how it is I like kill
everyone with kindness but it's but it's
not even up front it really is truly who
I am which might even kill them more
and what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson I've learned
in my life in your 25 years and I'm in
my 25 years yeah I would say
is really just how important it is to
just love people and not judge them for
real I really don't think people deserve
to be judged for almost anything like I
grew up with a younger brother who
is gay or bisexual or and I've just seen
him be made fun of and judged his entire
life it's been very very hard for him in
Texas in Texas yeah and he's still there
I'm hoping he can make it over at some
point
um but it's it's really just
heartbreaking and no one deserves that
we're all humans stop taking life so
seriously first the problem with the
hatred and judgment that others are
dishing out it's not going to change a
thing all you're doing is making
yourself more miserable exactly you're
making yourself more miserable and and
maybe the other person if they know that
you're judging them and hating on them
so yeah it literally just brings you
down whenever all you can do is focus on
the negatives about other people what is
even the point first of all yeah
excellent all right Emily thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you so
much absolutely you're delightful thank
you thank you